Now, I know that many convocation speeches...
...hinge on the variation of the "Do big things" mantra.
And that's important.
But I also think that it's equally important...
...to talk about the idea of "doing the small things in a big way".
Maybe doing small things in a big way...
...means giving that extra 10 bucks a month to charity,...
...if you really believe in it.
Or sending your mom flowers on a day other than Mother's Day.
Or striking up a friendly conversation with someone...
...who looks totally different from you.
Or trading your car for a bike, when the sun's out.
Whether you realize it or not, these things matter.
That extra 10 bucks just brought textbooks for a girl trying to get an education.
Those flowers?
Well, they just made your mom's whole week.
Your new friend's story will help you understand your own identity....
...in a totally different light.
And that bike?
Well, that bike is saving the planet.
Your actions, today and tomorrow, big and small, have an impact.
So, be kind, say please and thank you, and hold the door.
At this exact moment, you're all worried about what you're going to do...
...but don't worry about that stuff.
Figure out instead who you're going to be.
The rest will follow.
So, let me leave you with this.
If it excites you a lot and scares you a little, then you should probably do it.
Be bold, be brave, be open to the incredible opportunities in front of you.
Class of 2017, we need you.
The world needs you.
So, be the best versions of yourselves...
...and go make us all proud.